so as i mentioned earlier donald trump
continues to just be absent and missing
as president his schedule is clear
every single day some days he'll have a
private event like lunch with his own
vice president
but trump has essentially disappeared
publicly there's really no president
right now
and fortunately we're getting some
leadership on the virus
from joe biden some leadership on
climate from joe biden who recently
announced his climate team
otherwise we would really have no
leadership at all in the united states
right now
but being missing from the public did
not stop donald trump from having a
globally
embarrassing outburst on twitter over
the weekend truly horrifying
and shameful not talking about the
spiking cove deaths now
excuse me surpassing 3000 a day not
talking about his loss to joe biden
still hasn't conceded but just
continuing to spread debunked and
baseless voter fraud
lies now we dealt earlier with the cyber
hack
from russia and a couple of donald
trump's tweets over the weekend were
about that but i've already talked about
those in another story
but the weekend was just rife with lies
and pathetic red herrings
and distortions from donald trump most
of it
focused around continuing to claim that
he actually
won the election trump tweeting a quote
from right-wing propaganda network
oan quoting an anchor there i guess
named christina bob
who said quote the lie of the year is
that
joe biden won now of course that's not
true and at this point trump will go
anywhere he will
quote anyone who will say something that
trump
wants to believe whether or not he
really believes it i don't know
donald trump then attacking his former
national security adviser john bolton by
saying quote
what would bolton one of the dumbest
people in washington know
wasn't he the person who so stupidly
said on television
libyan solution when describing what the
u.s
was going to do for north korea i've got
plenty of other bolton
stupid stories remember donald trump
ran on hiring the best people and he
hired john bolton and if indeed john
bolton is as stupid as donald trump has
claimed him to be
for years now then it really says
something about donald trump now
to be clear bolton can be stupid or
smart and be a disaster politically i
happen to think john bolton is not a
dumb guy
but he's an absolutely horrible
reactionary i think trump is actually
wrong that bolton's stupid
i think bolton is a absolutely a
terrible person when it comes to policy
but i've seen no evidence that bolton is
actually
stupid donald trump then tweeting in all
caps simply
quote greatest election fraud
in the history of our country
that's obviously untrue and then donald
trump retweeting a conspiracy theorist
named jim hofft known as the gateway
pundit who runs a conspiracy website
who tweeted that quote simple math shows
biden claims 13 million more votes
than there were eligible voters who
voted in 2020
election now that is completely untrue
completely baseless but it doesn't
matter when the president tweets it
literally millions of people believe it
without even looking further that's the
real tragedy of this
donald trump also retweeting some of the
silliest dumbest arguments i've seen
from a right-wing radio host named kevin
mccullough
for example one with a map of the us by
county
which says biden supporters seem to be
really losing their minds
at how angry they get when you tell them
that biden won only about
16 only 16 percent of the counties
they get even angry about that than the
fact that they
are all supporting a cheater who's okay
with the cheating now
it's hard to parse the grammar there i
read it as as tweeted
but this is something that they've been
pulling out frequently lately
but it's meaningless they they are
arguing well if you just look at a list
of counties
joe biden didn't win that many counties
but of course
most of the people are in the counties
biden did win what
the population of the united states is
in the counties that biden won
disproportionately counties vary in
geographical size
counties vary in population the
percentage of counties you won is a
meaningless metric and in fact
they don't even seem to know this but
part of what leads to gerrymandering
is the drawing of these bizarre
districts
in politically advantageous ways and the
fact that you have lots of counties that
are geographically large with few people
when you put up a map of red and blue
counties it's part
it's a similar distortion to what we see
by gerrymandering
different distor it's it's similar in
its nature it's not the exact same data
that is being distorted
but there are just dozens and dozens of
these retweets of
conspiracy theorists and others and then
this morning donald trump sort of
capping off a humiliating weekend of
tweets
with the tweet big news coming out of
pennsylvania
very big illegal ballot drop that cannot
be accounted for
rigged election at least he's not
calling it a massive dump anymore
but it's still just as untrue and as
many of you may know
a week ago on december 14th every state
including pennsylvania had their
electors
vote pennsylvania has voted for joe
biden with their electoral votes
and that's it they've been teasing
things like this for weeks now
whoa big news out of nevada we're about
to get nevada
uh incredible what we massive dumps in
georgia we're about to take georgia
nothing is happening nothing is
happening and so
you know at a certain point trump will
go we're 30 days away
we've talked about what happens to
trump's twitter
after january 20th right now donald
trump has
protections on twitter for world leaders
where they are not subject to the same
rules that
you and i would be subject to when we
tweet it's uh
completely plausible that after donald
trump is no longer in power
uh he could be banned from twitter or
his tweets could even be taken down
we don't know that's more of an academic
question the big picture question
is does trump go quietly into the sweet
night
and he gets out of politics and we don't
hear from him anymore
or does trump go as far as on the other
side of this
does he go as far as announcing his 2024
campaign
on the day that joe biden becomes
president and does he campaign for the
next four years
which would create dramatically
different media environments and
dramatically different political
environments for the next four years
we won't know i guess until january 20th
but that will be the biggest factor in
determining what the next four years
are going to look like